Ah, to fly. As early as 1496, Leonardo da Vinci.
Let's see, this machine ought to fly? I only need to pedal a little bit.
Oh, you're much too big, Jumbo. You're way too much, friend.
Fly. Since Icarus, man's eternal dream.
Two centuries later, 1678, Besnier's wings.
1742, Bachfil's wings.
1806, Degas' ornithopter.
1854, Varian's ornithopter.
1868. A great step forward. Here's Stringfellow's steam engine triplane. Thomas Moyes' aerial steamer in 1875. Patin's monoplane in 1879. How many far-fetched dreams, fertile imaginations, and vain hopes until they all became fragile reality? 1895. Otto Lilienthal flies.
explain yes chief there he goes 1897 clima adair man could fly he could but he doesn't know how
he has to learn 1903 the wright brothers first flight 1906 the santos dumont takes off at bagatelle
1907 was as bike the years that follow bring strange machines the french airplane the danish
Elehammer, the American Russian, the American Signet, the English Safety, the French Givaudin,
the Italian Aero Curvo Ponzelli Miller, the French Davy, the English Edward Romboidle.
In 1909, Bleriot was to cross the English Channel.
In the war in 1914, what use could be made of aviation?
The English Avro, German Rumpler, the Italian Mackie, French Bad.
And why don't you try to fly upside down this time, huh?
It's Robert who'll be replacing you during your period of convalescence.
Good luck today, friends.
There, there.
Be able to land now.
There they are.
Papa, over there.
Can you help me?
Come and help me set the table for dinner.
I'm coming.
You like me, Mama?
Thank goodness, what a sight.
Now you're out of your mind, isn't she, Pierre?
Your mother's right, dear.
That outfit isn't proper.
But why?
Now you listen, will you?
I mean, can't you be modern?
Now you be still.
I hope I'm not late for dinner.
You're funny like that, you know, and with your short hair, you look almost like a wolf.
Well, in the next World War, I'll be a reporter and I'll be the first to see that.
Wow, wow, Pierre, you'll be a photographer.
Let's all drink to Robert's.
I owe my life to you.
Without them, we wouldn't be all together tonight, my friends.
Hey, Pierre, are you hurt?
Théo, would you like to dance?
Oh, would you stop bothering this young lady?
Mademoiselle, would you want to be with this dance?
Veacher, I'm a very important person.
President, Director, General of a large company.
And with me, you can expect to live what you'd call a dream life.
And what's so funny?
Well?
You late again, darling.
I'm sorry.
Oh, darling, you've been flirting with your place.
Well now, monsieur, during the war, I was...
The Treaty of Versailles had just been signed.
For some, it wasn't enough.
For others, too much.
Contained old grievances, the seeds of future conflict.
There, sir.
service we don't want any war heroes or daredevils uh we'll call you thanks please thanks all the
same cheer up pierre don't give up so soon you know as long as i work we'll be able to manage
you'll end up by finding work yes yes you'll see and try not to stop your mama matter hi there my
sweet papa something wrong i think that i'm finally going to accept that job as a mechanic the one
they offered me and you robert me i accepted to fly as a barnstormer and it pays well and wash your
Yes, mama. Oh, I forgot I got a letter from Papa in my pocket. Here.
Well, I've got something for you, too. There it is.
Oh, what is it? Oh, fantastic!
Are you pleased?
Whoa!
Is it real?
Well, sure, it's for a future reporter.
My application was finally accepted. I'll be flying.
You see?
1920, the American Senate refuses to join the League of Nations, which clung to worn-out illusion.
America isolates itself, breaks all its ties with a troubled Europe.
The Michael Vanzetti affair confirms their decision.
You see the first Nazi bronze shirts.
Italy, Mussolini's black shirts beat down socialism.
In Russia, all anti-revolutionary attempts failed.
In Ireland, there was war.
A bloody one.
So, how was that?
One day you'll end up killing yourself.
And above all, go easy, please.
This machine is very powerful.
Who's that?
That's Adrien Boulogne.
A pilot? She's an airplane pilot?
And she's a good one.
She's made a bet with Cordon that if she makes a single loop,
he'll give her the plane as a gift.
But she won't make it, I bet.
It's much too tough for a woman.
Yes, she's fantastic.
1920, Adrian Boland is the first woman pilot to cross the English Channel.
I want to learn to play.
You, what?
You're nuts.
It's not something for women.
And her, what's she?
Oh, well, she's a special case.
Yes, that's it.
Me too.
I'm special.
It's out of the question.
There's no use to insist.
Well, I hope you've understood me.
Now, just pay attention.
Careful.
1921, Adrian Boland will be the first fly over the Andes.
They treat themselves to the movies.
In 1921, there was the fight of the century in Jersey City, Dempsey and Carpentier.
The United States and Japan grow into great powers, while Europe declines.
Democracy doesn't work, while fascism grows.
1922, after a march on Rome by the not-too-impressive Blackshirts,
King Victor Emmanuel cedes power to their leader, Mussolini, to form a government.
Hello Fujita.
Latest news, get your news.
Get the latest news here, latest edition.
Can you sit down? I will paint your portrait.
Oh, not before I sell all my newspapers.
Here then, I'll buy them all.
The French Senate vetoes the women's right to vote.
A journalist writes,
It must be shown to women that they are by nature inferior, both morally and physically.
A fact that even they cannot deny.
This French journalist's name was Jaloux.
1923, a scandalous book, The Tomboy.
That's Ernest.
Oh, folks, come on.
You want a drink?
Okay, well, why not?
In Russia, the Secretary General of the Communist Party, Stalin, tries to gain power.
In Germany, Hitler's attempted putsch failed pitifully.
In Italy, the black shirts terrorized the people and won the elections.
Moiselle, would you like to join us for a touré?
You mean me?
Sure, someone pretty like you.
What do you want to drink, huh?
Robert, it's you at last.
My darling.
1924, in prison, Hitler writes Mein Kampf.
He includes all his ambitions.
Read the book.
Place, my friend, we dine together.
Me!
It's like you're finally home.
Oh, what's all that grease?
Oh, it's the very latest rage, dear. It's a beauty cream.
What's more, it revitalizes the skin.
You'll see. In two weeks, you won't be able to tell me from your daughter.
And my latest novelty, a stove that runs on electricity. My progress.
25. Art Deco and black musicals are the rage in Paris.
26. In Belgium, the Crown Prince Leopold and the Princess Astrid live in a fair.
It's to finish a barnstorming.
1926, at the movies, Monos Faust.
That same year in Paris, the franc is worth four cents.
My best photos, those I've taken during my reporting.
In Chicago, Al Capone runs the town.
Interesting.
And the women of America swoon with grief
at the news of the death of a slick-haired young man, Rudolph Valentino.
Good.
Gentlemen, come and see the very best review in Montmartre.
The show is starting in a few seconds.
The opulence of the post-war years is tone boring.
No one is interested in the air shows.
The tests are done and the plane is all tuned up.
Robert and a co-pilot will try to make the Great Crossing.
It's a first like so many before it.
Mickey Mouse is in the movies.
Last moments of a carefree life.
Oh.
Move anymore.
Be memorable.
It takes a lot of courage to try this.
Yeah.
Good luck.
Never see Robert again or hear of him.
Such was the heartbreak those times.
Oh then, my darling, be courageous.
And have some coffee for my new coffee pot.
Would you look at this thing?
The latest gift I got from your dear father, a radio.
May the 21st, 1927. Sensational news.
You see it? The paper paid me 100 francs.
That's real great.
Let's celebrate this. Come on with us, I'll pay for the cinema.
It's the first of the talkies, the jazz singer. I've heard that it's sensational.
You make them blue, honey boy.
1927, the execution of Sacco and Vanzetti in the United States causes riots in Europe.
And their names were cleared 50 years too late.
In 1928, Maurice Bastier beats the non-stop flight record.
And she beats many more records.
1928, the Brion Kellogg Pact, signed by 60 countries, outlaws war.
Had the world grown up?
My dear, it's an electric iron.
I'll get it.
It's me.
Oh, yes, it's out here.
There's another piece.
Watch this.
and now i present my latest invention a vacuum cleaner and it cleans what all your dust is
electric i'm going to give a demonstration what's wrong with this thing will you cut that out come
Come here! Has it come here?
Yeah, did you hear me?
Will you cut that out, you silly dick?
No, as I told you, immediately!
Come down!
Lay down! Yeah!
Go on!
Machina, quite such a moracious habitat!
Our New York correspondent has some alarming news about the American stock market.
The economic crisis threatens to capitulate the American nation into a serious economic crisis.
The Wall Street Crash, 1929. All hope for peace is dead.
With the American Depression spread to the whole world, there would soon be 40 million unemployed.
The post-war celebration was over.
1932, our young reporter friend Pierrot will be a privileged witness to the world-shattering events of his time.
So long. See you soon.
Well, that was the end of the carefree years.
The Depression brought the rise of fascism.
In 1932, with the powerful support of German capital and the military, the Nazis won 37% of the vote.
In 1933, Hitler comes to power with a vote of 89%.
And to consolidate the nation, he uses racism, hatred for the Jews, as scapegoats for all that was wrong, and he mobilized it.
Italy was controlled by Mussolini.
In most European countries, capitalism was bankrupt and hiding behind totalitarianism.
In America, Roosevelt is elected and soon there would be the New Deal.
That same year, Amelia Earhart crosses the Atlantic.
1934, in France, the Stavisky scandal causes rioting.
1936, Hitler occupies the Rhineland.
Großenberg, errettung, Uldres Holges!
I think it's very nice here.
What are you people doing in my field? Get out of here!
If only France had moved.
I'm not gonna tell you again!
But France, politically shaky, preferred the good life.
I said get out!
It was at that time...
No.
Italy pounced on Ethiopia for an untimely conquest, and the weakness of the League of Nations would be known to all.
In Spain, a terrible civil war that would serve as a training ground for all totalitarian armies.
In Soviet Russia, the trials and executions attained proportions greater than at any other time in history.
1938, Austria is annexed to Germany.
Then it was Czechoslovakia's turn.
Chamberlain and Deladier's visit to Munich, where they capitulated to Hitler, was called a triumph.
1939, to the amazement of the French, English, and Polish, Stalin signed a pact of non-aggression with Hitler, which left Poland wide open to him.
And eight days later, on the 1st of September, war.
Poland is invaded.
61 nations, 100 million enlisted men would fight in the war.
War dead?
More than 50 million.
10 million civilians, women, children, old people exterminated in the Nazi concentration camps, defying all humanity in the name of hatred.
The Enola Gay flies towards Hiroshima.
What victory?
Europe, the cradle of humanity, is no longer.
In February 1945 at Yalta, what were to be the main lines of peace were drawn up.
A shaky peace.
It was based on a balance of terror.
And what of man in all this?
Man, barely able to stand on his own two legs.